Well, good morning church.
Yes, this means it is the final sermon in this incredible
series we've been walking through over the last few months.
Uh, really closing the entire narrative of first
and second Samuel, the story of David.
As we've watched this journey play out over the last few
months and even a over a year ago, we started First Samuel
Plus, as you can tell, because
of the decorations we're moving into the Christmas season.
And so, uh, next week
I did not anticipate that was gonna get claps.
So, okay, so, uh, it's great. I love Christmas two.
Um, next week we are starting a new series through, uh,
Luke one and two.
So we're gonna actually just take the story of this king
that we've been looking for.
The promised one, he actually showed up.
And so that's this promise to presence idea.
What's the actual story of how that happened?
The not some unique spin on Christmas.
We're just taking the literal story
and explaining what happened.
You'll also want to get the daily email
that goes alongside it.
There'll be a QR code.
You can see that you might, uh, go ahead
and scan that if you want, uh,
from December one through December 24.
We'll be a daily email helping you read
through the advent season of, of what, who is God,
who is Jesus that we're looking at in Luke one
and two, Aaron Ferguson, one of our elders went ahead
and, uh, put that together for us.
And so you can grab that
and if you are already on the list from last
year, you're on a list still.
But, uh, if you want a new fresh take on Christmas,
go ahead and take a look at that.
But like I said, today we are finishing our journey really,
uh, through all that we've seen God do in David's life
and, and in Israel in that season of time, he saw
how the first king Saul, he had died
and then David ascends to the throne, kinda rises
to the throne and all
that God's blessings brought with that.
There was a covenant that God made with David,
and it really just an incredible spiritual,
powerful moment in David's life, season of life.
The rise to the throne was that.
But we also saw how David, just like Saul had done,
he ventured into sin, got in trouble,
especially Bathsheba and Uriah.
There was some mess there, of course, how much
that cost him, cost his family, cost his nation.
So there was a rise and there was a fall.
He was covered by grace.
We've seen that over and over again, covered by grace.
But there were consequences for his sin.
Well, sadly, here at the end
of David's life here at Second Samuel chapter
24, it happens again.
And there is a great cost to what David does.
And so my hope today is to again, point to God's character,
to his holiness, to his righteousness of his justice,
but also to to point to the nature of his grace.
That yes, consequences of sin are there
and and they will be there.
But God, how he, how he provides forgiveness for those
who humbly return to him hope we can all walk away
with that kind of idea as we go towards him.
Let's pray towards that now.
Lord, thank you for the opportunity to be here
studying your word, worshiping you, responding
to you being in fellowship and community together.
We pray, God, that you in your glory would
shine brightly today.
That it's not my words, it's not anything I've come up with.
It's you by your spirit, speaking through your word,
applying it to each of our lives uniquely and
and showing us what we need to learn and remember and obey
and receive as well today.
Do that for your glory and our good. In Jesus' name, amen.
And so as we turn to Second Samuel chapter 24,
we're gonna look first at verse one down
through the first part of verse 10,
and you'll see where we're going with this.
Second Samuel 24 verse one, to start again,
the anger of the Lord was kindled against Israel
and he incited David against them saying,
go number Israel and Judah.
So the king said to Joab, the commander of the army who was
with him, go through all the tribes of Israel from Dan
to be Sheba and number the people
that I may know, the number of the people.
But Joab said to the king, may the Lord your God add
to the people a hundred times as many
as they are while the eyes of my Lord,
the kings still see it,
but why does my Lord the king delight in this thing?
But the king's word prevailed against
Joab and the commanders of the army.
So Joab and the commanders
of the Army went out from the presence of the king
to number the people of Israel.
They crossed the Jordan began from rower, from the city
that's in the middle of the valley toward
Gad and onto Jayer.
Then they came to Gilead, to Kadesh
and land of Hitite came to Dan.
From Dan. They went to Seiden from the fortress of Tyre
and to all the cities, the HIEs
and the Canaanites, they went out
to the Neba Judah at Be Sheva.
I went through that really quickly.
Those are just a bunch of cities scattered all
over the land.
North, south, east, west.
They went everywhere,
all over the land counting people, verse eight.
So when they had gone through all the land, they came
to Jerusalem at the end of nine months and 20 days.
And Joab gave the sum of the numbering
of the people to the king.
In Israel. There were 800,000 valiant men who drew the sword
and the men of Judah were 500,000, verse 10.
But David's heart struck him
after he had numbered the people.
We'll come back and finish that here in a second,
but let's just first start examining what's going on here.
Now, there's a lot of debates actually about this passage,
and it revolves around verse one where it says that God
incited David.
So the question is, did God cause David to sin like this?
Well, that can't be true
because we see in James one 13, the New Testament says this,
let no one say when he's tempted, I'm being tempted by God.
For God cannot be tempted with evil,
and he himself tempts no one.
So what was happening here?
Well, notice at the beginning of verse one,
we've gotta read carefully.
The beginning of verse one said, the anger
of the Lord was kindled against Israel already,
like before anything with David,
before anything with this census, it was already
the anger the Lord was incited against kindled against
Israel, which means that David, himself
or entire nation was already sinning.
Something was already disobedient to God.
God was just using what was happening next, what happened in
what we read to expose it
and to discipline his people.
There's a complicating factor here that causes the question
because there's a parallel passage
to this actually in one Chronicles 21, where it
specifically says it was Satan
who incited David to number the people.
And so is that a contradiction like the Bible
just, oh, well, there's the proof.
The Bible can't be trusted
because it says here and here, and it's different.
Actually, what I believe is going on here is that sometimes
God sovereignly permits Satan to act
in order to accomplish God's purposes.
You can see it back in Genesis 50 verse 20, Joseph
sold into slavery by his brothers.
That would've been Satan's temptation,
but it ended up that what you intended for evil,
God intended for good, that many
people would be kept alive, right?
So it was God's allowing something so
that this would come about his purpose.
It's the same thing I believe is happening here.
God does that all the time.
God uses Satan's efforts in various ways,
like to refine or to discipline
or to purify disobedient believers.
I believe that's what's happening here.
God allowed Satan to tempt David,
kinda like Job in a way.
Satan goes to God, can I do this to him?
And God's like, okay, God allowed Satan
to tempt David and David gave in.
David was fully responsible for giving in
and sinning in this way.
And so what was the problem that God wanted
to expose in David using this mechanism?
Well, I believe most likely it was pride,
trusting in himself his own strength.
He was wanting to make sure his army was strong enough,
and it kind of feels noble
because his, he's at the end of his life,
and so his son Solomon is about to take over as the king.
And so you can imagine David even saying, well,
I wanna make sure my son has enough military strength
to be able to project to the world
that we're okay as the transition happens.
I wanna make sure Solomon's got what he needs.
We need to count and make sure.
Well, that's still pride
because all of that language is about trusting in something
other than the one who protects them.
It's trusting in your own strength.
And so the pride in David or,
or maybe he was actually just saying, man,
I wanna know how many people I have.
I wanna see how great I am.
That's all pride led to this kind of sin.
So clearly David, at the end
of his life needed further refining.
And don't forget what I said at the right
before that, David was at the end of his life here.
He had followed Yahweh for decades.
He was called a man after God's own heart.
He wrote half the Psalms that we have in our Bibles today.
He was this spiritual giant, yet he was not
beyond the reach of devastating sin.
Maybe he was trusting in himself,
maybe he was leaning on his past, whatever it was,
he was failing to press forward in his relationship
with God, and it got him in serious
trouble again.
It led him to have to repent again.
I don't know, I'm trying to put myself in David's shoes.
Maybe he even felt immune to the things
that tripped him up when he was younger in his life.
It's like, I got that beat.
I don't have to worry about that anymore. I can handle it.
And maybe he felt immune,
like I don't have to worry about it.
Now here, here's the point.
My hope, like when I face temptation,
when you face temptation,
my hope cannot be, should not be.
My hope is not in myself.
It's in Christ alone. Like when you face temptation.
When I face temptation, our only hope for victory,
our only hope to overcome it, our only hope
to beat it is not in ourselves in any way.
It's not in anything in us.
Our hope is in Christ.
Do not think that
because you followed the Lord for many years
or, or because that you have this heart
after God like David did, and you love Jesus
and you, you look like you do or or don't think that just
because you are here right now
and you go to church most often
and you're those kind of people, right?
Don't think that somehow you are immune to sin.
The moment we trust in our own spiritual resume,
the moment we count our victories over things in the past,
instead of casting ourselves upon Christ,
that's the moment we are ripe for tripping up.
I love this verse. We always memorize verse 13
of one Corinthians 10, but, but listen to verse 12.
Let anyone who thinks he stands take heed lest he fall.
Like, if I think I've got it together, I'm doing okay.
I'm right there. I've, I've got it all figured out.
Be afraid because that's the time.
Most likely you're gonna fall,
stay alert again, David needed,
and God wanted to expose the pride
lurking in David's heart and hear me.
He wants to expose the pride lurking in your heart.
And in my heart, he exalts those
who are humble and he humbles those who exalt themselves.
So here's what all this means for us.
It means we must flee self-confidence.
And I don't say that in a way like the world says,
be confident in yourself and all these things, okay?
What I'm talking about here is fleeing the self-confidence
that your strength you think is in your
own spiritual track record.
My strength is in my track record,
but it's not that my strength is not in
that my strength is in finished work for me.
The battle against sin is never over until you die
or until Jesus comes back.
It's a day by day moment by moment struggle against
this enemy we have.
And so we have to stand in the victory that he has already.
Christ has already won for us.
All the battles that you think you've conquered,
you can't rest in those.
You can't trust those
because they will not last in that moment.
If you're not leaning on Christ, they can help you.
They can build a foundation,
but they can't last if you're not in the
moment resting in Christ.
And I'm gonna be honest, this is, this is what I've noticed
as I get to sit with this all week, I,
I've recognized that this is something
I'm especially prone to.
I can look back in my life
and I can see a lot of God's spiritual blessings in me.
I can see that I've preached a lot of sermons.
I've studied the Bible a long time.
I've read a lot of books. I've got
two degrees from seminary.
I've got this stuff. I all of these things, these,
this resume and in those really good things, hear me,
it can make it really easy
to coast in my relationship with God.
Like there's enough past investment in here that is
so easy for me
to just make it look like I've got
it all together spiritually.
Like I can manufacture enough, I can pull enough of this out
and I can say, well, here's how this works.
And I can sound good, look like I know how to do that
because I've got decades of this process built into me.
The problem with that, think about
what happens when water gets
stagnant, right?
It gets nasty. It becomes a hazard.
When water stops moving, it becomes a breeding ground
for mosquitoes, for bacteria.
It becomes something you would never want to be a part of.
It grows algae. It gets disgusting because it's not moving.
But think about flowing, clear, fresh water.
It's appealing because it's moving.
It doesn't grow the same level of grossness
because it's moving, it's active, it's circulating,
it stays fresh.
Listen, we must not trust in ourselves
or our past victories or our spiritual efforts.
We must be constantly pushing forward into our relationship
with Christ into his words, the living water
that he promises.
The fountain that never stops flowing,
that never will be unsatisfying to us.
That's the only way we'll stay growing
in our relationship with God.
That's the only way we'll stay vigilant against the
temptation that is constantly coming our way.
And so we're gonna remind ourselves a couple times today
of the truths that I believe God brought outta this passage.
And the way we're gonna remind ourselves is we're all gonna
read out loud that point together.
You'll notice all three points are written in first person.
Like you will be saying that
as if you're the one saying it, right?
'cause you are saying it. That was confusing.
But you'll say it from the heart.
And and there's something about saying it and hearing it
and reading it all together.
It just burns it deeper into our conscience.
So we're gonna put the point on the screen
and we're all gonna read it out loud together.
We're gonna do that with all the points today.
But this one's the first.
And so just read it, reminding yourself
and those around you of, of this truth today.
My hope, when tempted is not in myself.
It's in Christ believe that,
live that well,
sadly, what we've learned throughout second Samuel is
that like, you know, we're covered spiritually.
We, we've talked about the gospel a lot during this series.
The consequences though of sin are often very great.
And so I want you to see the results Of David's sin here.
Look at verse 10 down through verse 17.
But David's heart struck him
after he had numbered the people, meaning he felt convicted.
And David said to the Lord, I have sinned greatly in
what I've done, but now, oh Lord,
please take away the iniquity of your servant
for I've done very foolishly.
And when David arose in the morning, the word
of the Lord came to the prophet God, David seer saying, go
and say to David, dust says the Lord.
Three things I offer you, choose one of them
that I may do it to you.
So God came to David and told him
and said to him, shall three years of famine come
to you in their land?
Or will you flee three months
before your foes while they pursue you?
Or shall there be three days pestilence or plague
or infection in your land?
Now consider and decide what answer I shall return
to him who sent me.
Then David said to God, I'm in great distress.
Let us fall into the hand of the Lord
for his mercy is great,
but let me not fall into the hand of man.
So, so the Lord sent a pestilence on Israel from the morning
until the appointed time,
and there died of the people from Dan to Beersheba,
70,000 men.
And when the angel stretched out his hand toward Jerusalem
to destroy it, the Lord relented from the calamity
and said to the angel who was working, destruction
among the people, it's enough now stay your hand.
And the angel of the Lord was by the threshing floor
of Una, the jebusite.
Then David spoke to the Lord when he saw the
angel who was striking the people.
And he said, behold, I have sinned and I've done wickedly,
but these sheep, what have they done?
Please let your hand be against me
and against my father's house.
And so again, think about what just happened.
David sinned by pridefully numbering the soldiers,
and God disciplined him.
And surprisingly, this is wild.
It it, I don't know if it ever has happened any other time,
but God let David choose which consequence he was gonna get.
He gave him three options, said, which one would you prefer?
And all bad, but which one would you prefer?
And David felt the pain of his sin in his heart.
And he said in verse 14, let us fall into the hands
of the Lord for his mercy is great.
Don't let us fall into the hands of men.
Meaning, I don't wanna be chased around.
I don't wanna be in battle anymore.
God, I I'm just giving myself to you.
And we'll come back to that again later.
But notice here, he chose that his mercy is great.
He chose that. He says, I believe God's merciful.
But notice that even in the hands of this merciful God,
there was a deep pain experienced both by David
and by the people.
You think back to David's sin, with Bathsheba.
With Uriah, that whole thing there, that cost five lives,
this sin driven by pride and self-reliance.
It costs 70,000 lives.
Like let that number pierce your soul.
70,000 fathers sons, brothers,
all dead because a godly man gave in to temptation.
And I know some of you're sitting there thinking like
that doesn't, that's not fair.
What do those guys do? 70,000 families wrecked by this.
Like what? And it's hard, I know.
But don't let the enemy deceive you
or distract you in this moment.
The reality is our sins are never private.
You think about throwing a rock into a pond, right?
The ripples go out all the way to the edges of the pond.
Well, it seems here in verse 17
that David finally recognized the
horror of what he had done.
He'd saw this effect and he said, I've sinned.
I've done wickedly. But these sheep, what have they done?
This is part of the agony of repentance.
You recognize what you've done and you turn from it
and you turn back to God.
But part of the pain of it is recognizing that our sin
doesn't just wound us.
It affects others. It hurts others. It wounds others.
It grieves God.
It brings about destruction in our world and in our lives
and our families.
Our sin is never just about us.
That's the point we need to be reminded of today.
Friends like so clearly this does so strongly, this does.
It's that sin will cost me more than I could ever imagine.
I mean, this has been a summary of the entire book.
In many ways, sin will cost you far more
than you can ever imagine.
David could not have imagined what his sin against Bathsheba
and Uriah would bring about in his family and in his nation.
There's no way he could have foreseen the high cost
of boasting about his army size.
It's probably the same for you, isn't it?
Like you look back at your life
and you see the carnage of the choices you've made and sin
and you've, you've seen the effects of sin in your life
and in those around you.
And listen, you look back on those things
and if you see that pain
and sorrow, I'm guessing that you would go back
and wouldn't do the same thing again, right?
Like if you had a choice, if you could see it,
my guess is if you'd have known what comes from that sin,
that thought, that action, whatever it was,
you probably wouldn't have done it.
But here, man, here we discover one of the enemy's
main attacks against us.
Let's put ourselves back on the front end
before we've sinned.
We're in the fog of temptation. Like we, we all feel that.
We all know what that feels like.
You're in the fog of temptation. It's hard to see anything.
All you know is this temptation's coming your way.
And he, the enemy, makes it hard to see
that there will be any consequences on the other side
of doing that thing, right?
He makes it seem, I'm just give you a couple examples.
He makes it seem like, man, you're, you're fine.
This isn't gonna hurt anyone else.
Let me just give you some examples.
He lies to you and gets you to believe that
what you're doing, you're just chatting with
that woman online, it's not a big deal.
Nobody's gonna find out until it destroys your family.
You, He, he gets you to rationalize that purchase
or to go into debt like that because you deserve it or
because God wants you to enjoy life failing
to acknowledge the growing financial bondage
that will limit generosity
and cause undue stress in your life.
'cause you, you needed it. You deserve it.
He deceives you into thinking that it's just a few drinks
until you get behind the wheel and end up in prison.
Or worse, you end someone's life.
He dangles that a in front of you
that you would get if you just cheat like everybody else is.
But you fail to see the, the cost that could be
of losing a scholarship or getting kicked outta school.
You, you think it's just a few videos or I'm just scrolling
and I'm just kind of relaxing a little bit.
But you fail to realize
how it is desensitizing your conscience, feeding discontent
and stealing time from deeper relationships.
Like this is why church, this is why we must be vigilant
because the devil and the world
and even your flesh are constantly working
to pull you away from God, shoving
sins, potential effects under the rug, getting you
to not look at those.
Don't worry about it. Just feed your flesh right now.
Just satisfy that desire right now. That's what you need.
Don't worry about that. That's not really gonna happen.
It is all a lie.
Again, if you were able
to see the consequences on the other side of
what you're choosing to do in the moment, you would much
less likely do that.
Same thing. If I knew the cost
of what I'm about to do
and I could see the effect on the other side,
I would be a lot less likely to do what I'm about to do.
It's not the only reason we don't sin, right?
Our first priority is that we love God enough.
But this is a really good barrier too.
It helps us down the road to holiness.
And so similar to, we did the first one.
This is another truth. We need to keep pounding
into our souls to learn it, to remember it, to live by it.
We have to remember this.
So we're gonna read this one out loud as well.
Read it again with the idea to teach yourself.
Remind yourself of these truths. Here's the second point.
Sin will cost me more than I could ever imagine.
Remember that.
Now we come to the end of Second Samuel
and May, it feels pretty tragic, doesn't it?
In many ways it is. But I wanna see
just a couple things.
David said here in this passage,
he was convicted in his heart over
what he'd done in verse 10.
He said, I've sinned greatly in what I've done.
Take away the iniquity of your servant.
I've acted foolishly. He's recognizing, man, I'm off.
I I didn't do this. I blew it.
Verse 14, he calls upon the great mercy of God, verse
17, I've sinned.
I've done wickedly. Let your hand be against me, not them.
Like I should take ownership. I am owning this.
I messed up God.
And then watch what he does next.
This is verses 18 through the very end of the chapter.
Watch this. And Gad came that day to David
and said to him, go up, raise Antar
to the Lord on the threshing floor of Aruna, the Jebusite.
We had already seen that a few verses earlier.
So David went up at God's word as the Lord commanded.
When Aruna looked down, he saw the king
and his servants coming on toward him.
And Aruna went out and paid homage to the king with his face
to the ground and said, why is my Lord the king?
Come to his servant. And David said,
to buy the threshing floor from you in order
to build an altar to the Lord
that the plague may be averted from the people.
Then Aruna said to David,
let my Lord the king take an offer up.
What seems good to him?
Here's the oxen for the burnt offering.
The threshing sludges, the yolks of the oxen for the wood.
All this una gives to the king.
Una said to the king, may the Lord your God accept you.
But the king said to Una, no, but I will buy it from you.
And for a price I love this.
I will not offer burnt offerings to the Lord my God,
that cost me nothing.
So David bought the threshing floor
and the oxen for 50 shekels of silver.
And David built there analar to the Lord
and offered burnt offerings and peace offerings.
And the Lord responded to the plea for the land,
and the plague was averted from Israel.
As dark as this conclusion has been,
this is the breathtaking grace that shines through it.
Watch this. David had learned
where to run when he failed.
He had learned he shouldn't run to military strength.
He shouldn't run to political alliances.
He shouldn't run to try
to cover up his sin like he did the first time with Uriah.
He shouldn't try to run to any of those things.
He had learned he he should throw himself on
the mercy of God.
And so what he does here, he, he builds an altar. Why?
To stay the hand of God's judgment against his people
to stop it, to say, there's gotta be a way
for this not to continue.
Because it was continuing
that angel was standing there with the judgment.
He was doing the work.
And David's like, we gotta stop this somehow.
So he built an altar, he offered sacrifices,
and he turned back to God in repentance and worship.
And what happened? God stopped.
Those two things were happening concurrently.
What God said to the angel, he said, at the same time, David
was doing what he was doing with the altar,
and this is why we can't skim over the details in the
Bible, this threshing floor.
It's like, well, okay, what in the world?
Why is this matter? Well, this threshing floor
of Aruna, the place where judgment stopped
a few chapters later became the site of the temple.
It was the very location that Solomon,
a few years later built the temple on
that very spot.
It became the place where God would meet
with his people for centuries to come.
The place where sacrifices were made to cover people's sin.
So even in the discipline that's happening in two Samuel 24,
God was working redemption, even in the judgment.
He's preparing the way for grace,
that threshing floor became holy ground
because David met God there in brokenness, in faith.
And the offerings given were what covered David's sin.
The place of judgment became the place
mercy came from.
You see some parallels here.
David knew Mercy was available if he came to Yahweh,
if he came to God.
The same truth for us.
Mercy is available for us if we return to Christ.
Mercy is available if I return to Christ.
Here's how all this parallels for us today.
Christian, Listen, you are going to sin.
We shouldn't want to. We shouldn't try to,
but you are going to, until Jesus comes back
or until you die, at some point you are going to sin again.
And so when you do, don't run from him.
Run to him. Don't run away from God. Run to him. Why?
Because his mercies are so great.
You can fall on the mercies of God
because you know Christ has born the judgment
that you deserve for your sin.
He has become the sufficient offering to cover all
of your sin.
That's the reality of that threshing floor.
Be becoming the place of mercy.
The reality here is that the plague
of spiritual death was coming for you.
The judgment of God is on you and me.
Apart from any intervention,
we are sinners deserving of God's wrath.
The plague of spiritual death was coming for you.
Yet the spiritual beauty is that the shed blood of Christ is
what cleanses you from all of that sin.
The judgment has been taken for you.
And so it wasn't a threshing floor anymore.
It was a hill with a cross planted on it
where the judgment became the place
of mercy for you and for me.
That's why you don't have to run away from him anymore.
You can run to him when you sin.
You can repent, you can worship and you can watch.
As God transforms the place
of your failure into the very place where his presence meets
with you, you become
his temple where the sacrifices have already been paid
by Jesus' blood and his presence fills you just like he
filled the temple back then judgment becomes mercy.
So I invite the worship leaders to come back out now and,
and, and we're gonna repeat that point in worship.
We're gonna repeat that same point, that third point
with a spirit of joy and humility and gratitude
and awe with this idea of all that we've seen,
the judgment turning to mercy.
We've seen it. And let's remind ourselves, remind each other
of that truth.
So here we go. It's gonna be up on the screen.
You'll see it. Mercy is available.
If I return to Christ, we can do better than that.
Mercy is available if I return to Christ.
Let's believe that. Let's say it again.
That's for you. That's for you, friend.
I don't know what you've done. He does.
And you know what?
He paid for it. He's provided for it.
And so the invitation today is to run to him.
Mercy's available. If I return
to Christ, it's available for you.
Return to him. Run to him like David.
Run to the mercy seat. Run to the altar of Christ.
The very definition of mercy
and grace is that you don't deserve it.
So don't feel like you're too far gone. Don't feel like you.
You can't earn it because you can't earn it.
He earned it for you. That's the beauty of the gospel.
It's hope Mercy is available if I return to Christ.
And so we're gonna have our prayer partners along the
walls in this room.
If you need to talk to someone, if you're in that place
and you're like, I, I don't know what to do with this,
and you're so broken and you just tears, it's okay.
Mercy's available. If you return
to Christ, they're not Christ.
They're gonna help you towards him.
They're gonna pray for you're gonna encourage you.
Or maybe it's not that. Maybe it is.
This place up here is open all the time.
And you just say, I just, I just need to symbolize
to myself this idea of running to the altar of Christ
or right at your seat, face down whatever it is that you're,
you're in your heart saying, Jesus, I need you.
You're repenting.
And whatever the cost,
your sin is demanded in your life, Mercy's available.
Doesn't mean life will be perfect like it was before.
But mercy eternally is available
for those who return to Christ.
So run to him. Run to him in temptation
before you even do it.
Run to him. Hope in him. He's your hope. Run to him.
Look to the lamb who died for your sin.
Run to him today and find mercy
and grace in your time of need.
Um.